Matt how can restaurants best utilize
snapchat Matt I think content content
content man make one of your sous-chefs
super popular and viral on snapchat by
putting out good content it's all the
same game in it works for everybody
there's content and there's
distributions a good way to put a bonus
the quality of the content where you put
it when there's new places that are
blowing up there's more upside and
snapchats more fruitful than Facebook
right now video for somebody that's up
and coming even though Facebook video is
a big big big platform it's harder to
break through that noise that's
supplying the man of tension supply and
demand of attention so how do you make
it pop you put out content what's good
and interesting and funny is it gonna be
funny because you've got a funny sous
chef is it informational because you've
got a chef that just puts out how to
make deep meals do you have a bartender
that's really charismatic that knows how
to do mix drinks like what's gonna work
then you use everything else they do
does your men you have your snapchat
being promoted but you know is your
front window have it promoted do you run
ads to build up your page is it in
everybody's email signatures in the
organization so you've got to create
you've got to go to fertile grounds and
then you have to use all other platforms
to drive awareness to that fertile
ground because most people in the
beginning don't know those places exists